mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalker
a triangle is divided by eight parallel
lines that are equally spaced from each
other as shown
starting from the top
color each alternate region in blue
then color the remaining regions in red
if the area of the blue region is equal
to 145
what is the area of the red region
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
i will first review similar triangles
and then i will solve the problem
first let's go over similar triangles
according to euclid similar triangles
are to one another in the squared ratio
of their corresponding sides
if we have two similar triangles whose
corresponding sides are b and b times x
then the ratio of their areas will be
equal to the square of x so a2 over a1
is equal to x squared
or a2 is equal to a1 multiplied by x
squared
this is a formula we all have learned in
geometry but where does it actually come
from
let's quickly prove it
we have these two triangles let's now
construct the height of each triangle
suppose this triangle has a height equal
to h which means this other triangle
will have a height equal to h times x
now a1 is equal to b times h over 2 and
a2 is equal to bx multiplied by hx over
2.
in the formula for a2 we can group the x
terms so we have bh multiplied by x
squared
we can then rearrange this formula and
we have bh over 2 multiplied by x
squared but bh over 2 is exactly equal
to a1 so we can substitute here and thus
we've proven that a2 is equal to a1
multiplied by x squared so if the sides
are in a ratio of x their areas will be
in a ratio of x squared and thus we've
proven this
now let's solve the problem
suppose the smallest triangle at the top
has an area that's equal to a
what's the area of this red stripe
it will be equal to the area of this
larger similar triangle minus the area
of the small triangle
suppose the small triangle has a height
equal to h
then the next triangle has a height
that's equal to 2 times h
we know the area the small triangle is
equal to a
by the principle of similar triangles
this larger similar triangle will have
an area that's in proportion to the side
length ratio squared so it will be a
multiplied by 2 squared
thus its area will be equal to a times 4
which is equal to 4a
thus the area this red stripe is equal
to 4a minus a which is equal to 3a
now there's another way that you could
see the area of the red stripe
the smallest triangle has an area equal
to a and we can fit exactly three of
these in this red stripe thus its area
will be equal to 3a
we can then calculate the area of the
next stripe in a similar fashion
we know that its area will be equal to
this triangle minus the area of this
triangle
we can use the principle of similar
triangles to get that the larger
triangle has an area equal to 9a
then the other triangle will have an
area equal to 4a so this area will be
equal to 5a
once again we can also try and fit the
small triangles inside of the stripe and
we'll get exactly five of these
triangles
we can now continue the pattern to solve
for the area of each stripe
the next stripe will have an area that's
equal to 4 squared minus 3 squared
that's equal to 7 multiplied by a so
this will be equal to 7a
we could also calculate it by putting
seven of these small triangles in there
we now see a pattern each next stripe
will have an area that's two more than
the previous one
so this stripe will be equal to 9a
we also fit nine triangles in there
then it'll be equal to 11a
we then have it equal to 13a
then it'll be equal to 15a and the final
stripe will be equal to 17a
let's now just focus on the blue stripes
we know that the total area will be
equal to 145.
the total area of these blue stripes
will be equal to a plus 5a plus 9a plus
13a plus 17a and that's equal to 45a
thus we get a is equal to 145 over 45
which is equal to 29 over 9.
from here we can focus on the area of
the red stripes
the total area will be 3a plus 7a plus
11a plus 15a which is equal to exactly
36a
we substitute in for a
multiply it by 36 and we get this is
equal to 116.
thus the red stripes have a total area
equal to 116
and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
you